quieres o no quieres cuántas veces has
iniciado un rompecabezas empiezas a
ponerlo vas avanzando pieza por pieza y
de repente en algún punto te llega a
saturar pasa una semana dos no avanzas
te frustras te desesperas lo tomas y lo
guardas
pasan los meses lo vuelves a poner
empiezas nuevamente desde el contorno
vas avanzando avanzando pero llega
nuevamente ese punto en el cual te a
tórax
la desesperación regresa la frustración
no avanzas lo tomas y lo vuelves a
guardar
pasan unos meses inclusive años y
entonces ya ni te acordás que lo tenías
lo encuentras lo pone sobre la mesa
empiezas a armarlo y llega otra vez el
punto en el cual te vuelves a toral
solamente que esta vez tú te prometes
que lo vas a terminar sí o sí
con paciencia empiezas pieza por pieza a
ver en dónde está el error hasta que
logras avanzar vas avanzando vas
avanzando y entonces ya tienes casi todo
completo nada más falta unir dos bloques
cuando lo tienes lo intentas hacer y no
embona las esperanza y frustración
regresan a ti lo tomas con calma
respiras observas las piezas y te das
cuenta que llegaste a forzar un par
las tomas las intercambias las pones y
ahora sí como por arte de magia el
rompecabezas se completa machine piece
es uniendo piezas y me gusta el nombre
del evento porque la vida en sí misma es
como un rompecabezas en el cual vamos
uniendo pieza por pieza para poder ir
completando aquello que nosotros
queremos sin embargo como en la vida
misma en el rompecabezas en la vida nos
digamos atorar y no sabemos cómo seguir
adelante y hoy quiero que hablemos de
esas dos últimas piezas que las forzamos
y hasta que no las cambiamos es que
podemos seguir fluyendo porque cuantas
veces tú has intentado embonar piezas
que no corresponden ya qué me refiero
con esto cuántas veces has intentado tú
pertenecer a un grupo donde sabes
perfectamente que no perteneces
cuántas veces has forzado tener una
relación de pareja con alguien solamente
porque te gusta
cuántas veces te has aferrado un
proyecto cuando todo tu ser interior te
está gritando que ya lo dejes que ya no
te hace feliz
porque lo hacemos
porque no nos escuchamos no nos
observamos y al no escucharnos y
observarnos no nos conocemos y ahí está
el error pasamos la vida tratando de
vivir la vida de otras personas tratando
de embonar piezas donde simplemente no
están destinadas a morar por lo tanto la
primera pieza clave para poder completar
ese rompecabezas es el autoconocimiento
es decir que te conozcas a ti mismo bien
que tanto sabes de ti que te gusta que
no que te apasiona en que eres bueno es
más
cómo te sientes hoy con tus resultados
cómo te sientes hoy en tus relaciones
cómo te sientes hoy con tu trabajo
te estás forzando o no
estamos en un automático y es evidente
que al estar en este ritmo dejamos de
observarlos y escucharnos y
evidentemente pues no nos conocemos ni
siquiera sabemos que nos gusta que no
obviamente no vamos a poder responder la
pregunta quién soy o por qué soy como
soy
abre el costo para alguien de no
conocerse es altísimo ya que pasa la
vida tomando decisiones basado en lo que
los demás quieren en lugar de tomar las
decisiones basado en lo que sí quiere
cuando una persona se conoce tomar
decisiones es muy sencillo es muy fácil
saber decir que sí es muy fácil saber
decir que no es muy fácil salirse de una
relación de pareja que ya no te está
sumando es muy fácil salirse de un
trabajo porque ya te tiene harto es muy
fácil dejar un negocio cuando ya
simplemente no estás feliz y todo lo
contrario cuando si estás feliz puedes
quedarte
qué es lo que verdaderamente quieres en
tu vida
lo que verdaderamente quieres en tu vida
la razón número uno por la cual las
personas no consiguen lo que quieren es
porque simplemente no saben lo que
quieren
qué propósito tienes en tu vida para qué
estás haciendo las cosas tienes la
claridad
ejemplo para que esta salida de aquí
para decir que el térek fue un evento
padrísimo soy muy cool
o para llevar tu información y aplicarla
a tu casa
qué te duele
porque te duele cuáles son tus
debilidades
de tal forma que tú puedas saber de qué
pie cojeas y puedas hacer algo al
respecto cuáles son tus fortalezas para
que entonces a puntales ahí y puedas
ponerlas al servicio de los demás
a qué le tienes miedo
observa t
estás jugando a ganar o estás jugando a
no perder en tu vida si juegas a ganar
sales sin miedo por tu resultado el que
quieras el sueño que tú quieras
cuando juegas a no perder
está saliendo temeroso
temiendo perder lo poquito que puede
llegar a tener
en el arte de la guerra junto menciona
si tú te conoces a ti mismo y con
nuestra tu enemigo
y en 100 batallas correrá peligro
si te conoces a ti pero no conoces a tu
enemigo vas a ganar una batalla y vas a
perder otra
pero si no te conoces tú y no conoces a
tu enemigo en todas las batallas correrá
peligro por eso la importancia de auto
conocerte la primera pieza clave para el
rompecabezas
la segunda pieza clave es que te decidas
a hacerlo y hacerlo
dejar de fantasear y concretar a hacer
lo que tengas que hacer decidir llevar
hasta las últimas consecuencias el sueño
meta lo que tú quieras cumplir por
decidir no me refiero a tener buenas
intenciones
no me refiero a decir que lo vas a
intentar
por decidir me refiero a que respondas
que si cuando te haces la pregunta
quiero o no quiero
que cada una de tus células vibre que
sientas un escalofrío como recorre y es
en un instante
cuando dejas de poner pretextos y
excusas y tomas acción con el primer
paso
recuerdo hace unos años
quiere asistir al mundial de brasil-2014
era marzo yo tenía ahorrado cierta
cantidad de dinero
pero no me va a alcanzar ya había
cotizado de me iba alcanzar
el mundial iniciaba en junio
empecé a ver en internet una promoción
de un banco donde básicamente consistía
en que la persona que más likes tuviera
lo iban a llevar completamente gratis
vi que la promoción iba a terminar al
siguiente día que yo la vi era un sábado
como por las 5 o 6 de la tarde iba a
terminar a la medianoche del domingo
y cuántas cuántos llevaba la persona con
más likes más o menos eran como 300 dije
bueno tengo poco tiempo pero 300 suena
reto más no imposible
y entonces hablé con mi hermana ya la
tarjeta habiente de este banco subimos
la foto y ese día empecé a escribirle a
todos mis amigos por favor ayúdanos con
un like ayúdanos y empezamos a subir en
los likes más o menos llegamos como a
como 30 20 más o menos
deja dormir
y esa noche me dije a mí mismo bueno si
rebajamos durante estas horas de sueño
16 50 60 likes el domingo me lo va a
pasar todo el día pidiendo likes me
despierto el domingo por la mañana tomó
el celular de repente veo que lo
rebasamos digo pues a darle pongo la
computadora me siento del chat y
entonces empiezo a escribirle a todos
los amigos con los cuales hablo
frecuentemente oye medios online
medioson like y empezamos a subir pero
llegó el punto en el que se me acabaron
los amigos que frecuenta entonces ya me
da penita los que no les hablaba en dos
años despedirse
entonces estaba sentado me paraba
iba al baño regresaba
me armaba de valor le pedía 23 likes me
paraba iba a tomar agua regresaba pedía
23 likes iba venía y eso estuve cerca de
mediodía hasta el mediodía llegó el
punto en el cual me harté me llegaban
mil ideas haz un vídeo hace esto y esto
y de repente ocurrió en un momento lo
recuerdo perfectamente estaba en la sala
y me dije a mí mismo a ver fernando
viñas
quieres ir a brasil o no quieres ir a
brasil
en ese momento se crea un silencio
y yo solito me respondí 6 te quiero y
sentí un escalofrío de arriba abajo
y entonces me dije a mí mismo entonces
deja de ser te [ __ ] y haz lo que
tengas que hacer
si quieres subir el vídeo hazlo
si tienes que ir de perfil en perfil
hazlo pero deja de estar esperanzado a
que las cosas cambien por sí solas
en ese momento tomé la cámara el tripié
la puse y con todo el miedo del mundo
empecé a hablar le estaba pidiendo a mis
amigos que compartieron este vídeo
porque íbamos a ganar no con sus likes
sino con los likes de sus amigos
y empecé a ir de perfil en perfil
pidiendo la ayuda
y para hacerte el cuento corto quedamos
en noveno lugar
lo que conseguimos la meta pero a final
de cuentas me quedé satisfecho oye
fernando para entonces para que nos
contaste esa historia ahí no termina la
historia pasaron unos días y entonces
recibo la llamada de un amigo muy
querido me dice oye fer
mi familia y yo tú ya sabes que vamos a
ir nos vamos a regresar bueno
la familia se va a regresar y yo me voy
a quedar solo en julio y ya tenemos
pagado todo el departamento
si quieres caerle kylie yo te regalo el
hospedaje
si quieres ir consíguete tu boleto de
avión consigue tu boleto del partido y
adelante
y muchísimas gracias tomó la palabra
vamos a ver qué podemos hacer por el
boleto cuando los ven próximo martes a
las 2 de la mañana
y ahora las dos de la mañana que es
bueno me tienes a la una de la mañana te
explico un poquito la última fase de
venta de boletos todo el mundo se trata
de conectar a la página internet el
primero que entró el primero que pague
el primero que se lo lleve entonces
imagínate todos los fanáticos del mundo
tratan de entrar una página internet
casi siempre tardas entre una hora dos
horas tres horas siguientes
estoy a la una a la mañana moviendo la
pantalla para que no se suspende yo
poder entrar a hacer las filas para
poder acceder rápidamente pasaporte en
mano tarjeta de crédito en mano
a las 2 de la mañana en punto abre el
sistema pasaron menos de 10 minutos y yo
ya estaba en el portal comprando el
boleto empecé a buscar boletos de avión
y los encontré a mitad de precio a que
voy con todo esto
cuando tú te decides hacer las cosas
algo dentro de ti cambia tus células
todas cada una de tus células vibra de
una manera diferente que la vida te
responde hay una frase que a mí me
encanta que dice cuando tú te decides
toma esa acción la providencia te
responde
texas de pretextos y empiezas a dar el
primer paso y se empiezan a abrir
puertas que antes no se podían abrir que
tú no hubieras podido abrir
deja de fantasear y haz que las cosas
sucedan
si te caes
texaco es el polvo
si no pudiste por acá lo haces por la
derecha y si no puedes por la derecha lo
haces por la izquierda y si no lo haces
por la izquierda lo haces por arriba y
si no puedes por arriba lo haces por
abajo
pero hazlo
deja de fantasear
no sé cuál sea tu sueño
pero por favor deja de ser como el perro
que agulla
una vez un corredor salió y empezó a
escuchar como un perro aullaba con un
dolor pero esos dolores que hasta
lastiman escucharlo
así de aún
el corredor de vuelta vaya qué onda con
el pobre perro que le están haciendo
un día dos días tres días
de repente se harta y dice bueno voy a
tocar la puerta a ver qué onda con el
vecino porque lo está maltratando el
vecino lo abre
le dice oiga porque está maltratando su
perro yo no estoy maltratando a ningún
perro pase y observen
pasa el señor de repente ve a el perro
echado y aullando con el dolor de verdad
muy desgarrador aún aún
el corredor le dice yo creo que lo
maltrataban porque llora mira es muy
fácil el perro está echado sobre un
tapete y abajo del tapete hay un clavo y
es el que lo lastima y hace que a ud
oiga pero porque no se mueve el perro
el clavo lo está lastimando lo
suficiente para quejarse pero aún no
está está clavando lo suficiente para
que se mueva
no sé cuáles sean tus sueños y no sé qué
tan comprometido estás para llevarlo a
las últimas consecuencias
si no quieres está bien
pero si en verdad quieres
concreta la acción concreta tu meta y
que su historia sea la siguiente que
inspira al mundo muchas gracias